bien on discute et je te retrouves sur
piste soit ce qui est de mise à jour qui
a tué cinq nouveaux niveaux bien se fait
pas longtemps qu'on n'a pas joué à ce
jeu je suis tout excité on a été juste
ici il fallait ptc vaisseau c'est parti
ok j'ai une idée
alors là on ouvre le bal avec un
véhicule hors norme le voici le voilà ne
vous mariez pas demain qu'on aimerait ça
va être super venez voir rien est un
sujet pas besoin de parler juste jouer à
mr j'oublie les routes
ok moi par des procédés vaisseau alors
on va voir si ma stratégie est bonne eh
bien je me le film the way un mouton qui
est beau mais c'est pour ça que j'ai mis
un petit pistons à l'avant mais il vit
un mouton tu vois je t'ai pas vu avec ta
bon il va venir au magnifique
c'est là que ça va être chaud attention
attention hein
non non j'ai pas bien c'est été auteur
aussi ok nouvelle tentative véhicule l'a
logiquement on peut embêter 3 à toi là
vous allez voir vous allez pouvoir vous
pouvez vous rigolez mais c'est facile de
rm vous allez voir c'est beaucoup moins
facile de gagner ce niveau voilà qu'est
ce tu pas peur on a perdu des pièces
quand même d'un voyage à nice mais
qassem atta
yoga sens mais pourquoi moi pourquoi vos
vaisseaux explose bref la sphère de
refonte de ce vaisseau auquel avait de
la v2 et là attention mon gars savent
être révolutionnaire déjà le véhicule
est beaucoup plus solide
même si on dirait pas avec des [ __ ]
de canons à eau banny quel est ce que
l'eau sam
m'a dit ok fin voilà patar question à
faire il m'a tout casser pour casser
[Musique]
cloisonne à j'en ai marre
ok j'en ai commandé un truc
révolutionnaire pas besoin de tout ce
bordel vous allez voir un tout con tout
simple mais ça va mal
ok le dernier va falloir bien vu en ont
il a pété les canaux au nom on est baisé
j'aime pas comment c'est possible
on a fait un beau gars comment j'ai
galéré à passer cet homme exceptionnel
j'étais saoul est carrément l elorn et
bonne humeur c'est parti on va enchaîner
volet est délivrée cristal
le ca ok on va faire les techniques
classiques j'ai envie de vous du rhin le
bon canon assez dur quand même à me
voilà qui est oui dit soudas est malade
fa cup et voilà y'a plus qu'à chercher
nos pistes ah ben voilà plus il vient
nous c'est super ça on va le pousser
tout simplement aller cricri tu viens
allez allez on y va
alors si m attends je vais débit trop
bien là c'était bien plus rapide que le
niveau d'avant bizarrement bien être
avec moi
voilà ça s'est fait couper 90% des
pouces pour les enfants qu'est-ce qui
coupe on a des lames as a regardé des
circulaires sow bateau et voilà mais tu
vas faire toi non mais j'ai pas pris en
compte cinq avec des gars qui allait
attaquer excusez moi je dois couper tout
mon truc
on se détend ça leur poussée ça va
pousser arrêté à la salle où il chantera
tout casser on m'aurait pas [ __ ] on
dirait que les pizzas fdp qui vient de
couper tout volé s'est offert au québec
des cultive hockey
et voilà les gars ses lapins and so
sorry qu'est ce que ces animaux d'après
détruit 80 % du village pour les enfants
et voilà tout bêtement
ça va le faire c'est parti et voilà ah
oui d'accord la barre on va avancer quoi
at en écrasant les poules des moutons ça
compte
tu as la poule c'est une grenade faut
des bons irait du mouton du bon mouton
napoule et voilà c'est passé à grâce aux
moutons et sur les animaux étaient
foutues un zones vivantes like et un
truc pour adultes s'il vous plaît
détruire toutes les tentes
alors je veux bien mais l'offre a fait
un truc vraiment blindés 1 on va tester
leurs attaques voire away ou qui bloque
pas enfin un truc pour adultes ça va
chier
donc très simple et efficace vous allez
voir au hockey ce à quoi plomber plan b
plombé les maigres m et this topic
what you're gonna do when i'm permet pas
aux ue rapporte que petit à petit au
hockey
messieurs dames voici executors qui
exécutent les ennemis sans aucun
problème et en plus il est blindé le
haut enfin regarder attendais mais j'ai
quand même pas les piques
non mais ça abusé elle a un recul
il ya tout qui tous et vont tous mourir
allez dans les boules égalé dans les
boules oleko en purée et près de tout
comme des abrutis
voilà moi ah ah non il y en a là bas
[ __ ] spar et spar et spar bla bla a
vanté son auteur ça on s'en bat les c
est qu on a un truc tout terrain à l'est
[Musique]
amen
bah
iam soit puis moi je crois qu'on a la
dernière journée l'avant dernière je
sais plus détruire 80% des monuments
avec des grosses tornade bien m'attarde
ok c'est parti actuellement le skin va
parler vous allez voir ça va être
vraiment exceptionnel et doit y avoir
très peu de temps maintenant
la puck hop la table à moi deux au pl -
oh la la la la
jean-pierre votre vidéo sur piscine jeu
d'action vous a plu ce cas n'hésitez pas
à aller mais comme d'habitude mais ça
fait toujours autant plaisir 1 sauf
qu'on passe aux 45 minutes par niveau
parce qu'on a tardé ça c'est chiant on
s'empoigne vidéo dessus sur les nouveaux
niveaux avec grand plaisir et puis on se
retrouve tribu dans une prochaine vidéo
pour pas dire demain à la porte et
moulins jazz du monde pis
[Musique]
oh